[Music]
so much better
hey I'm ash Crossin here in Orlando
celebrating 40 years of Star Wars
looking at the past present and future
which is episode 8 the last Jedi are you
going full frontal in this movie he
might do you I mean you remember that
shot that we saw in the teaser trailer
was just looking about the chest so we
might need to go down and check out
what's happening with his body it's been
okay no he's not okay
I mean looks really messed up in that CD
trailer I hope you can get get well soon
Finn I'm doing all right I'm John I'm
doing fine but feeling that hey I don't
know about him and where today is I
think you're gonna be having a lot of
scenes with Kelly Marie Tran what can
you tell me about the character dynamic
and working with her
I mean Kenny's character is an absolute
fan of big deal in the resistance now
you know about it you know between seven
and eight people have now heard about
the amazing things that finish dining
and now he's like you know waving and
saying hi to all the you know resistant
ladies around and you know what is that
kind of transition it's great but it is
it's a fun time the dynamic between them
is is it's very interesting Ben sees a
lot of himself in her and she's still
trying to figure out her place you know
as Ryan said she's not a soul Josh she's
not a pilot so she's kind of figure out
what can she input that's important to
the good fight also this weekend was a
big celebration of Carrie Fisher's life
is there any moment that really sticks
out to you when you think about her my
car is simply a hilarious I was on a
strict diet for episode 8 and as Shido
trying to say lean and trim but
unfortunately on a day my spirit failed
and so I went to Carrie's trailer and
she obliged to give me some chocolates
and she was okay with that
Ben do you want to be it's fine and I
did hey you know and that for me is it's
a it's a is something that proves that
she was very much about individuality
and about what what makes you you
you